WAYNE PIEKARSKI:
Do you want to get
your apps on the big screen?
Well, we've made it
easier than ever before.
I'm Wayne Piekarski, a
Developer Advocate at Google.
And today, I'm going to tell you
about the new Cast SDK Version
3.
In January 2013, we
launched the Google Cast SDK
to allow developers to extend
their Android, Chrome or iOS
apps to the big screen
in people's living rooms.
Since then, we've learned a
lot from our content partners
and from third-party developers
about what it takes to create
great Cast-enabled apps.
Based on their feedback, we've
developed a new, simplified
Version 3 API for
the Google Cast SDK.
It simplifies several complex
parts of the previous SDK
and addresses the
major pain points.
This new SDK
significantly reduces
the amount of code needed
to Cast-enable your app.
It also provides a consistent
API across Android and iOS,
with Chrome following later.
The new Cast SDK
provides UI widgets
that fully comply with the
Cast UX design checklist.
For example, this includes
an introductory overlay
to introduce users
to the Cast button,
and a Cast button widget
that automatically manages
its visibility and
state and provides
all the necessary
dialogs for users
to select and
disconnect devices.
On Android, we show a Cast
notification with media
controls when the user
is casting content,
and lockscreen controls
to control media
playback without
unlocking your phone.
There are also
[? persistent ?] controls
for controlling
the media playback
while the user is
browsing within your app,
and a fullscreen
expanded control
to show the media playback
status there, as well.
Similarly for the
Cast device UI,
the new Cast SDK now provides
reusable receiver widgets
that comply with the
Cast Design Checklist.
These widgets can be used in
your own custom receiver app
so you can add
custom business logic
and support for
your media's DRM.
The new receiver SDK
will be available soon.
The new Cast SDK has
a singleton context
object to manage all the
interactions with the API.
And on Android, it
eliminates the need
to deal with Google API client.
The new SDK now provides
automatic device discovery
so that you don't have to
manage that in your code.
The Cast dialog supports
audio devices, video devices,
and device groups
with no extra work.
There is centralized Cast
session state management
that makes it easy to launch
your app on the Cast device
and start media playback.
There's also an automatic
reconnection service
that handles network issues
and automatically reconnects
media sessions if you
return to the living room.
There is a media control
object, and associated listeners
are provided to manage
all the media playback.
And finally, physical
volume buttons
are automatically
handled as well.
So the new Cast SDK
enables developers
to target all Cast
devices, including
Chromecast, Cast for audio,
Cast TV, and Android TV devices.
This new SDK makes
it faster and easier
to develop a Cast-enabled app.
And as new Cast
features are added,
your app will get these
features automatically
when you use Version 3
widgets and code modules.
So that's a quick tour
of the great new features
in the Google Cast
SDK Version 3.
Make sure you check out
our online resources,
and also join us on our Google+
community to ask questions
and share information.
So that's it for now.
I'm Wayne Piekarski, and
I'll see you next time.
[ELECTRONIC MUSIC PLAYING]